the thing is whenever I look at a
political movement especially the
ideological build I think okay there's a
bunch of things here for fine
what are you against you know because
one of the things that people who adopt
an ideological position like to presume
is that all of the right is on their
side and that makes them very
unconscious of their shadow let's say
from the Union perspective the Nazis had
all sorts of positive reasons for what
they were doing but you know the
negative reasons were there too and you
could easily make it in a case that the
negative reasons were really the reasons
and when I look at India logs I always
think yeah yeah that's what you're for
sure but I don't believe all the good
people are on your side and B I know
that negative motivations are more
powerful than positive ones so you say
you're four things but you're against
them too so let's let's start with that
so I thought think I started thinking
about this after I'd read George Orwell
I love George Orwell by the way do you
how many of you know who the George
Orwell is Wow
really that's impressive how many don't
ok well that's that's good that's
amazing how the hell did you learn about
George Orwell is it 1984 fundamentally
or Animal Farm Animal Farm
ok ok well that's good because George
Orwell now I tell you George Orwell was
the first Western intellectual who
figured out what the hell was going on
in the Soviet Union and he did that in
the mid 40s early you know it was
complicated because we sort of knew what
was happening in the 20s and the 30s you
know there was Lenin and that wasn't so
good there was the Russian Civil War
there was the idea of universal
communism that wasn't such a good idea
you know for as far as people who didn't
want to be communist were concerned and
then there was what happened in the
Ukraine in the 1930s so it was like yeah
you know the evidence was starting to
pile up but unfortunately what happened
was a Spanish Civil War and the lefties
were pretty much the good guys in the
Spanish Civil War right it was like a
microcosm of the Second World War the
lefties were fighting the fascists and
some of the lefties were communists but
a lot of them were also people who were
I think genuinely fighting for freedom
and a lot of North American literary
figures went
Spain to fight on the side of the know
you know against the fascists and so
fair enough
you know the fascists were obviously you
know reprehensible clearly and so and so
that kind of muddied the water right
because the fascists were bad and then
that sort of means that people that are
fighting them their guard and some of
them are communists and there was good
there was pretty good reason for people
to be radical socialists at that point
in human history because the plight of
the working man was relatively
unpleasant George Orwell wrote a book
called Road to Wigan Pier and he went up
to this town that was a coal mining town
and he he stayed with the coal miners
for a while and just looked at their
life so here here's a part of their life
so you basically work a seven and a half
hour shift when you're a coal miner you
think oh that's not too bad by 1930
standards it's like yeah except you have
to go down to them core mine tunnels you
know like they're not eight feet high
and carpeted they're like four and a
half feet high and rough and poorly lit
and the air is terrible and so basically
you have to chimp walk or crawl up to
three miles just to get to work and then
you have to do that at the end of your
shift
and you don't get paid for that that's
just that's your commute right right so
you know it was no bloody well and then
of course what you're doing when you get
there is like it's absolutely filthy
it's unbelievably noisy it's brutally
difficult
he said that coal miners they have no
teeth because they're like because of
their living conditions but their bodies
were absolutely perfect they were
unbelievably powerful and strong because
all they did was incredibly intense
physical labor but it was bloody rough
and the housing those people had is like
50 families for one outhouse that's
probably good enough to describe it and
often they were row houses and the row
houses had no back doors that may had no
paths between them and all the outhouses
were at the back so that meant if you
were was like 20 below and it was the
winter and you were sick then you get to
go all the way around the block to your
damn out house or maybe there's only one
there and you light up
50 people so that you know yeah so and
or well he was or well was an
upper-class guy basically and he was
trying to help himself overcome his
upper-class prejudices and it was a real
documentarian of the terrible working
conditions of of working class people
and he wrote this book called road to we
could peer but one of the things that
Orwell said he wrote this story about
these poor goddamn coal miners and you
think well yeah it's like how about some
social legislation so that these people
and their children aren't just
absolutely brutalized non-stop no but
then he wrote the last half of the book
and he wrote it for the left book club
which was a socialist group that would
publish a book every month or so and
what he did was he he wrote a critique
of socialism of pretty socialism and he
said yeah this sucks man it's like we
should be on the sorry of these working
people but the Socialists I meet they're
not on the side of the working people
they're like tweed wearing middle-class
hyper intellectuals who never go
anywhere near the working class because
of their class prejudices and for all
sorts of other reasons they don't like
the poor at all they just hate the rich
and I thought I had been a member of the
NDP for a long time at that point there
was always something a little off about
it especially the more radical and
economy what's with you guys like just
it doesn't look like benevolence as far
as I could tell there's a lot of whining
and complaining and resentment it's like
what that's what's that about I read or
what I thought aha right if you hate
this successful if you hate the rich who
are rich by the way is whoever has more
money than you like that's how you
define rich and the best way to mask
your resentment is to pretend that
you're on the side of the poor and are
you I read that I thought that's exactly
right and then that's part of also what
made me psychoanalytically oriented
because one thing psychoanalysts always
do always is if you say you're here's
how I'm positively predisposed the
psychoanalyst says how are you using
that to mask something easy and
malevolent
and that's always that's a very very
useful question start always correct
right but but it's correct a lot more
than people generally like to think you
know it's like the mothering head grab
the mother or the winch and Hansel and
Gretel you know this story right
this guy gets married he's got a couple
of kids
his new wife doesn't really like the
kids you have a hundred times higher
chance by the way of being abused by a
stepparent than the biological parent
just so you know
so the stepmother doesn't like the kid
she tells the guy well why do you just
go put those kids out in the woods sold
oh so they're lost kids right they have
nowhere to go so they're wandering
around out there in the forest what
happens they come across a gingerbread
house you think wow man you're a
starving kid just your bread house
that's good news right not only is it a
house but it's made out of candy how
could anything possibly be any better so
when they go well and then there's this
grandmother they take care and you know
she starts to fatten them up
she puts I think it's Hansel in the cage
and she gets Gretel
after a while to basically work as their
scullery maid and it quick becomes quite
obvious to the children that she's
actually fattening them up so that she
can put them in the oven and eat them
and so I think what Hansel does is I
think Gretel gives him this life bone
from some animal and the old witch is
half blind and everytime she reaches in
to sort of feel his leg he gives her the
bone and soul of like she's just not all
that interested meeting him in many ways
the kids end up pushing her in the oven
and closing it getting the hell out of
there so you know it's a happy ending
as far as fairy tale school but it's an
eatable story right it's a classic story
about an eatable family be bloody wary
of people who do too much for you right
it's like if you have a mother or any
other relative for that matter who's
fattening you up on mercy and candy the
probability that her basic goal is to
eat you enough so that you never leave
the probability is extraordinarily high
and that's no joke you know one of the
things that you do learn if you read
about the sorts of people who burst out
of their mother's basement and go shoot
up Dawson College's that often that's
exactly the situation they've been in
right they're burning with resentment
and they're useless and it's down in the
basement for five or six years you know
they don't have to leave they don't have
to become independent everything's done
for them so they never have to do
anything for themselves it's like it's
not pretty and so one of the rules for
dealing with people and I know this is
actually a rule for dealing with elderly
people in homes for retired people is do
not do anything for anyone they can do
for themselves you're stealing from them
when you do that and it's a great rule
of thumb for kids like once they can
dress themselves they dress themselves
if they can set the table even if it
takes 20 minutes it's like they're
setting the table you're not doing them
a favor by helping them do anything they
can do themselves and this gets caught
it's kind of harsh you know but it beats
the hell out of the witch in Hansel and
Gretel so so anyways you know one of the
things we're going to look at as well as
the dark side of positive motivations